once it's been a few years now of me
trying to process that and and touring
and actually building this business of
making and selling music and you know I
feel like I've finally come to the end
of that period of working with that
music and and I have been ready for some
time to begin the next thing I just
haven't known what it was so and I also
along the way have stopped writing music
largely here and there the song will
trickle out but I haven't I just haven't
had the time or energy or drive to focus
on writing stuff and I miss it so I
recently opened for they might be giants
for for about a week and a half at
several shows and I've been a fan of
theirs for years and years so it was a
real thrill to to open for them and our
audience is kind of overlap and you know
we share a sensibility that I stole from
them so so that was a big thrill I got
to know john linnell john Flansburg the
two main dudes and like them quite a bit
and at the end of my time with them John
Flansburg suggested to me that I make a
record I write a bunch of songs put a
band together and make a record and that
he would like to produce that record so
that is the thing that I'm working on
right now feverishly and with enormous
panicky feelings I am at home trying to
write songs that are good in
anticipation of playing them with actual
musicians and submitting them for the
approval of one of my heroes John
Flansburg and then going into a real
studio and spending a lot of money to
hire people who know what they're doing
to mix it and engineer it and master it
and to hire musicians who know how to
play their instruments these are all new
things for me
so it's a it's a very exciting project I
don't know what it's called I don't know
when it's coming but that is the thing
that I am very excited to be working on
right now and also very terrified to be
working on right now